Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American romantic comedy
called “The Invention of Lying.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie starts with a man narrating about a
world where humans have evolved into beings who
cannot tell a lie. Because of this, everyone
speaks the truth, including the beggars,
businessmen and even the beloved president
himself! The man introduces Mark Bellison
as a loser who is about to change his
luck by telling the world's first lie.
In the first scene, Mark approaches a beautiful
woman named Anna to take her on a first
date. Anna remarks with frustration that Mark
disturbed her while she was pleasuring herself.
She also comments that Mark is early
and needs to wait for her to get ready.
Mark expresses his worry that he can afford only a
cheaper restaurant. He further says that his boss
will probably fire him the next week and he does
not possess any financial assets despite being
in his late forties. Anna comes down and states
that she does not find Mark attractive enough.
Mark, who is used to getting similar attention
from women, sighs as they come out of the room.
The two then enter a restaurant where the waiter
is also brutally honest with them. He comments
that Anna is out of Mark's league and asks if she
is his daughter. Embarrassed, Mark thanks and asks
him to leave. He then asks Anna about herself.
She replies that she has a job that pays well,
so she is thriving in life. She gets a phone call
from her mother and tells her that Mark is not
good-looking and does not earn well. Upon her
mother's query, she answers that she is neither
kissing nor sharing the bed with him tonight. As
they leave, Mark thanks Anna for seeing him.
The scene moves to the Lecture Films studio,
where a man is demonstrating Napoleon's story.
As Mark appears, the man introduces him to the
crowd as a screenplay writer of the company.
Mark greets them with a smile which soon
changes to embarrassment when the man
truthfully announces Mark to be one of the least
successful employees who is getting fired soon.
Marks gets into the office and gets teased by
his colleague, Shelly, for his incompetence.
The boss, Anthony, comes out and fires Mark for
his pathetic writing about 'The Black Plague.'
At the same time, Mark discovers Anna's mail
stating that despite liking his company,
she is not interested in him on account
of his genetic look, financial condition,
and position in life, which are the determinants
for marrying people. Shelly rubs salt into Mark’s
wounds with her honesty, saying that the best
part of the mail is about his bad looks. While
Mark walks out of his office, Shelly and
Brad, Mark's competitor, say that they’ve
always loathed Mark working with them. Brad
further says that Mark will always be a loser.
Mark then enters a nursing home which in this
world is called 'A Sad Place for Hopeless Old
People.’ He is there to see his mother, Martha
Bellison. He tells Martha about losing his job.
He stresses that his mother is a loser, too,
and they come from a long line of losers.
Later at home, Mark's landlord approaches
him asking for the rent. After Mark shares
his condition, the landlord gives him a day to
get his stuff out of the house because he is no
longer competent to pay the rent. Mark goes
to a bank to close his account and withdraw
all the money he has. The cashier informs him
that they cannot help him close the account
because the system is down but they can provide
him the cash. The cashier then asks him his saving
amount as they cannot see through the system.
Mark says that he wants 800 dollars while his
heart beats rapidly. Just then, the system
comes back and the cashier checks his account
which has only 300 dollars. The cashier
says that the system might have been faulty
and believes Mark instead. She gives him 800
dollars and apologizes for the system's fault.
Mark gets astonished to get the amount he did
not have in his account and gets out of the
bank with a huge smile. He pays his rent and
comes back to his room. An overwhelmed Mark
shares to his friends about his deed being
unfathomable. He has just discovered lying,
but his friends, who are unfamiliar with the
concept, do not understand him. Mark tests his
new skill by changing his name every few minutes
but his friends believe him every time. Then,
he asks his friends what they would do first if
they get to do anything in the world. Greg says
that he would have intercourse with a girl. So to
try it, Mark goes outside and calls a girl past
him. She ignores him at first but stops at once
Mark mentions the ending of the world if she does
not have sex with him at the moment. The girl
hurriedly takes a surprised Mark to a motel.
When they reach there, Mark asks the girl to
introduce herself but the girl shouts that they
have to do it soon for the sake of the world. Mark
feels awkward himself and pretends to make a call
to NASA. He says that NASA has confirmed the world
will not end, and they need not sleep together.
Following that, he returns to his friends and
asks them, except for being with a girl, what
they would do if they could do anything in the
world. They cannot think of anything and in turn,
ask Mark what he would do. At once, Mark replies
that he would get all the money in the world.
After that, Mark and Greg go for a ride as
Greg drives the car totally drunk. A police
officer stops them and tries to arrest Greg for
drunk driving. But when Mark simply states that
his friend is not drunk, the officer believes
him. He even apologizes and leaves the scene.
The friends enter a casino where
Mark insists on playing roulette.
He plays his chance on 28 but sees that the
roulette is marked 35. So, he slyly points and
yells at everybody to look at something unusual
ahead. As everybody looks away, Mark drags his
bet on 35 and claims it. The dealer doesn’t
doubt him and provides Mark with his prize.
In a similar way, Mark cheats several times
and comes out of the casino with a large sum.
Later, he meets his depressed friend Frank in
an elevator, who shares that he is about to
commit suicide. Mark thinks about it and tells
Frank that he does not need to kill himself.
Frank believes him, and they both plan to hang out
later that night. Mark uses the technique he has
discovered to bring happiness to people's lives.
One night, Mark calls Anna and asks her for
another date. He explains that he has changed
and Anna should see it herself. Anna agrees
to go out with him for the last time.
After hanging the phone up, Mark turns
his TV on and sees a Lecture Film show in which
the narrator praises Brad's writing. Mark gets
an idea with this and goes to his table to
write a story with his newfound knowledge.
After completing it, he pours tea into it
and makes it look like a historical script.
Mark heads to the Lecture Film Studio and tells
his boss Anthony that he discovered historical
writing in an ancient chest earthed in a desert.
The writing has stories about the crashing
of a giant spaceship in Babylon, it catches
Anthony's attention. He asks his employees to
listen to the historic story as Mark recites it.
Mark reads that the earth was saved by aliens
in the fourteenth century. He adds that the alien
king wiped out human's memories to prevent them
from remembering the events. After 700 years, a
great writer Mark Bellison would stumble and be
put to human acknowledgment after being fired
by his crapy boss, Anthony, and mocked by his
colleagues, Shelby and Brad. The last sentence
of the script says that the Lecture Films
will be making a successful film and Mark will
become famous and wealthy. Everyone applauses,
believing the absurd writing while Brad's upset.
Anthony asks Mark to work on the film soon.
The next day, Mark takes Anna to an expensive
restaurant for their date. Anna congratulates Mark
for selling his script and asks about his family.
Mark shares that his father is an alcoholic and
his mother is in a nursing home. He plans to
take her out of the nursing home the next day
and get her a mansion. Mark finally asks Anna if
she wants to spend her life with him since he is
wealthy and successful. Though Anna likes him for
his wealth and success, she rejects him because
of his appearance and remarks that she does
not want her kids to be fat with snub noses.
Disappointed, Mark takes a sip of his drink
and answers a phone call. He finds out that
his mother is in critical condition and rushes to
the hospital. On her deathbed, Martha shares that
she is frightened of dying, for it is an eternity
of nothingness. As her vitals drop, Mark lies to
his mother saying that she will be in her favorite
place after death, young and juvenile, together
with her loved ones. As Martha hears this, she
smiles with excitement and soon passes away.
The doctor and nurses, who just heard Mark talk to
his mother, ask him to talk more about life after
death. But saddened by the loss, Mark returns back
home with Anna. As they wake up the next morning,
they share smiles knowing that they slept
on each other's shoulders the whole night.
Later, Mark drives to his home to find
a big crowd in front of it. Astonished,
he gets past the group while a woman screams
his name. The crowd quickly surrounds Mark
asking about events that will happen after death.
He somehow gets inside the house and turns the TV
to see a journalist reporting the scene outside.
Soon, Anna comes to his house and asks Mark what
he said to his mother. He shares everything
with her and Anna believes in it instantly.
She insists that Mark tell the people everything
he knows. Though in a dilemma, Mark reaches
for his pen and paper and starts writing.
After he is done, he comes out and reads it
aloud to the crowd. He says that there is a man in
the sky who knows everything. The man will provide
people with the best mansion, free ice cream,
and loved ones in the place after they die. He
warns that people who do bad things three times
in their life will be placed in terrible areas.
While people curse the man in the sky for causing
bad events, Mark convinces them that the man is
also responsible for all the good events happening
to people's lives. One of the women comes forth
and questions Mark how he knew all this.
Mark replies that the man in the sky told him
about it and leaves while the crowd clamors.
The following days' news headlines make titles
like NASA on the search of the man in the
sky, lowering the work productivity for people
thinking about Mansions after death and Man in
the sky responsible for disasters to miracles.
Mark goes to his office and hands over the
writing of The Black Plague to his boss.
The film becomes a super hit, and
Mark gets rich and famous overnight.
While sitting in a park, Mark remarks to Anna
about her being the sweetest person he has ever
met. Anna also says that she enjoys his
company. They get close to the kiss but
Anna backs away at the imagination of fat kids
with snub noses. She expresses that she loves
him but cannot give up the genetics thing.
Later that day, Anna comes to Mark's mansion
to give him a birthday card and informs him that
she is going on a date with Brad. She also shares
about her intentions of sleeping with Brad, which
Mark finds alarming. He convinces Anna not to
be involved in physical relations with anyone
before marriage. After saying this, Mark opens
his birthday card, which has a birthday coupon
for him to share the bed with her. She complains
that since they are not married, she will not
go out of the rule. Mark finds himself awkward
and says that it is a shame to waste the coupon.
Just then, Brad arrives and takes Anna to dinner.
Throughout the dinner, he talks about his
success and belittles Mark for his appearance.
While Anna watches Mark's interview on TV, her
mom changes the channel saying that Mark is never
going to be her friend, even though he speaks to
the man in the sky. Anna does not like her talking
about Mark like that and argues that he makes her
feel special. The mother strongly opposes Anna
with the argument that Mark will always be a loser
and his children will be the same. She calls Brad
at the moment and insists Anna talk to him.
Many weeks pass after the event. One day,
Anna suddenly appears at Mark’s front to
find him awful with long hair and beard.
She gives him the invitation card to her
wedding and asks him to attend it for her.
Mark requests her not to marry Brad but Anna
replies that she needs to do this because she
has little time to match a perfect genetic partner
and have the children she has always longed for.
On the day of Anna's wedding, Mark wakes up and
sees Greg in a suit, who offers him a shaver. He
shaves his beard and attends the wedding. The
priest asks the people if they offer a better
genetic match-up. As silence prevails, Mark
stands and puts forth his claim that Anna is
happier with him. Brad in turn questions Mark why
Anna is standing next to him if she is happy with
Mark. Brad tells Mark to ask the man in the sky
what's best for Anna to which Mark says that Anna
knows the best for her. Mark begins to walk out
but Anna insists he ask the man in the sky. Mark
finally confesses that there is no man in the sky
and he just told the story to relieve his mother
during her death. Anna further questions why he
did not lie to marry her. Mark replies that the
lie would not make a count. At last, Anna claims
that she wants little fat kids with snub noses.
Hearing this, Mark puts a smile on his face.
As the movie gets to the conclusion,
Mark and Anna are seen eating breakfast
with their little fat son while Anna is
pregnant with their second child.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.